hey guys what's up the following
conversation is with Chris Williamson
the host of the modern wisdom podcast
Chris has had conversations with a ton
of awesome people everyone from David
Goggins and Jocko wilnick to Jordan
Peterson and many others in this
conversation we talked about the 10
principles to survive and thrive in a
chaotic world this conversation was
recorded during lyceum Miami a
conference that I hosted this year I
always learned a ton every single time I
talk to Chris and I hope that you guys
enjoy this conversation here is my
conversation with Chris Williamson
explain your process for modern wisdom
and
how you pick gas and I look at the guest
selection as really the way you're
programming you're learning right you're
learning from these individuals in
conversation give people that context
before we get into these principles like
how do you pick the guests and how do
you go into a conversation trying to
understand what you're trying to learn
from them yeah so uh I got toward the
end of my 20s as a guy that maybe
outwardly had a lot of success the
Renown and I was running this big events
business in the UK and everything was
going great
but I didn't really understand myself or
the world around me and this was a time
when people like Jordan Peterson and
Alanda botton from the school of life
and Sam Harris and Joe Rogan were coming
along and they spoke to me and they gave
me insights that helped me to understand
myself and I figured well if I start a
podcast I can basically do this as much
as I need to do this as much as I want
and I can pick my own syllabus so very
much The Guiding rule is
who do I like who am I interested by who
Sparks my curiosity and if they meet
that criteria that's good enough for me
and Douglas Murray once said to me that
um
my instinct may lead me wrong but
they're the only thing that's ever led
me right
and it's pretty good yeah if you presume
that people have enjoyed the things that
you've done before because you're
interested in them
just keep following that and that is the
best heuristic that I've found
the first principle that we're going to
talk about today is uh in life we must
choose our regrets yeah so this is
Douglas again so this is almost exactly
a year ago and I'm sat in Manhattan
drinking in Manhattan probably my third
Manhattan of the evening I think about
two in the morning in Douglas's
apartment Midtown
and he was talking to me about
Christopher Hitchens the famous British
philosopher and he was lamenting to
Hitch about the fact that he had a bunch
of different options that he needed to
choose and because you have to deal with
by choosing one thing you can't do
another
he was suffering with this because both
of the things seemed great and he was
going to have this sort of avoidance
concern he had
um and I really wondered it was the
first time I'd ever heard in life we
must choose our regret so he's talking
to Hitch about this you can imagine he's
smoking probably in some British pub
somewhere with Chesterfield sofa and
bottle of scotch or something he says
Douglas in life we must choose our
regrets
I thought that's really interesting what
does he mean choose our regrets I never
considered it in that way because I'd
always gone through life under the
assumption that any regret was due to a
sub-optimal decision that had I have
made the right decision I could have
avoided the regret but
because you inevitably don't do one
thing by choosing another if I want to
go to the gym or go to the theme park by
going to the gym I don't go to the theme
park even if the gym was the right
choice
I'll always wonder what it was like to
go to the theme park so I I didn't
realize that regrets are baked into the
fabric of life right they're not a bug
they're a feature of having Limited
optionality
so I was like right okay that's
interesting but what does it mean that
we have to choose our regrets
okay well maybe it's that
when you come to make a decision given
the fact that you're going to have some
sense of I wonder what that other thing
could have been instead of wondering
about what decision you want to make
it's which regret could you live with
because the regret that you can live
with or that you can't live with is
evidently the decision that you should
make like which one you're going to live
with this decision for the rest of your
life right
right you're going to live with the open
loop of Woulda Shoulda Coulda what would
have happened and if one of these is a
regret that you can live with with more
ease than the other one that to me
seemed to make a good bit of sense and I
um I really liked the Insight in life
it's interesting when you view it as I'm
making a decision not what am I running
to but kind of what am I running away
from to some degree because uh it then
begs the question would you change some
of the decisions you've made in your
life from a regret minimization versus
you know what you want to do in the
moment right
regret minimizations are good um a good
way to look at it but yeah just it
really liberated me to think look
you're going to regret some things
that's fine
but choose your regrets and choose them
carefully the second principle
um is you can have anything you want but
you can't have everything you want which
when I saw you said that you wanted to
talk about this I was like oh man we're
gonna get real deep yeah well I mean you
know to a lot of the people that are in
the crowd they are probably type A
go-getters self-improvers you know by
being here you're already in the top
percentile of all people doing personal
development and self-learning right Atop
The rarified strata flying around the
earth next to the ISS
and one of the problems of that is that
you will want to be good at everything
that you try and do you'll start doing
pickleball and you'll become obsessed
with it until that's a personal Vice of
mine
um you start something new and you don't
want to suck right
and there's a quote from uh essentialism
by Greg McEwen and he says you have to
focus on progress toward a specific
thing in the medium term
or sacrifice meaningful progress toward
everything in the long term
and that is the Insight right you look
at world-class athletes they periodize
their training for the next
cycle it's going to be strengthened and
it's going to be speed then it's going
to be agility then it's going to be
skill work then it's going to be
conditioning and in life one of the
problems is as soon as you start to
focus on one thing I want to get really
good at growing my podcast let's say
maybe some fledgling podcasters in the
audience I want to get really good at
growing my podcast but I don't really
want to let my my body's condition drop
I want to stay in good shape and it
would be nice if I didn't you know if I
stayed on top of work and maybe I should
get a girlfriend and maybe I should do
and you go okay look
you can't do all of those things and if
you do you're going to be beaten by
somebody that focuses on one of those
things for a short period of time this
isn't forever you can periodize it but
you have to focus on progress toward a
specific thing in the medium term or
sacrifice progress meaningful progress
toward everything in the long term is
there an example in your life when
you've done this and it really worked
yes so for me during the pandemic that
was when I turned Pro with my podcast
and I just conceded the fact that
training was not going to be a priority
for me it was good because the gyms were
closed so I'd taken the local
environment and I was like right this is
going to actually Aid me Jim's assured
he was kind of sucked to train a home in
any case I wasn't fired up to go and do
more glute bridges in the living room
but
that made it easier for me and
the time that I would have spent in the
gym opened up time that I could spend on
the podcast
the third principle you have is a richer
vocabulary means a richer life yes so
this is uh Ludwig Wittgenstein there's a
quote from him that says the limits of
my language mean the limits of my world
what he means by this is that when you
have an idea in your head it's like a
smell it's a notion right it's just this
sort of ephemeral wishy-washy like what
actually is it until you put it into
words either by speaking it or writing
it down
it doesn't actually form anything
concrete you can't see it you can't play
with it you can't work out where it's
got holes it's just a notion right it's
an idea of an idea
what that means is that the tools with
which you draw your ideas
is your access to vocabulary it is your
access to language if you have to
squeeze Notions from your brain into
words that are either written or spoken
the breadth of the words that you have
allows you to portray those ideas more
precisely
that's it like it's just expose yourself
to new language as much as possible and
this has been something that's been very
fortunate for me first month being
British which is a you know a genetic
Advantage but secondly
also being able to uh get exposed to
great speakers Jordan Peterson's of the
world the rogans of the world you know
even David Goggins incredibly precise
speaker uh and that's what I use for the
people that want to become better
speakers Precision is the word it's not
more it's not less it's the word that
you meant to describe the thing that
you're trying to describe that's it when
Americans hear anyone from Britain
talking they immediately are like oh
they sound smart Chris we will determine
at the end whether that is true or not
that's fine that's okay the genetic
comment dings you immediately look I had
to I had to spend Fourth of July in
Austin last year it was very difficult
it was a very difficult time for me uh
it's very painful
um what that specific Insight uh reminds
me of is I think it's Eminem uh the
rapper said that he used to read the
dictionary because obviously when you're
rapping you want to have this very
robust vocabulary and be able to
understand what the words mean and
there's not just the rhyming of the
words but also there's kind of the
innuendos and all of that but what
you're really talking about is not just
specifically language you're also saying
the exposure to ideas right the exposure
to different types of content what is
your content intake like do you just
listen to podcasts all day and you're
like I have a podcast so I'm gonna
listen to another podcast or are there
other things that you consume that you
find really valuable that other people
could uh could use in their day-to-day
life one of the things that's been
really great for me is actually being
sub stack and the Advent of Articles so
there is an extension on Google Chrome
called send to Kindle it's made by
Amazon
if you have a Kindle you press this
button in the top corner of Google
Chrome whatever the web page is blog
post doesn't matter how long it is it
could be twenty thousand words it will
send it straight to your Kindle device
optimized you can highlight it you can
go through it and that for me has been
phenomenal because it's turned my Kindle
into a read later app type thing that
I'm not distracted from and it also has
exposed me to a bunch of other
um
differing ideas that I wouldn't do
usually there's another thing called the
browser I think it's actually the
browser.com they send you five articles
every day sometimes it's about how the
city of Jericho fell and next one's
about knitting and the Advent of
knitting in the 1600s or something and
it's just that's really great and other
than that it's crushing volumes of
YouTube and podcasts yeah are you a 1x
one and a half or 2x speed on YouTube 2x
is the speed I've worked myself up to
um but I remember you know
you do need to match up how much can I
comprehend and retain with how quick is
this going but if you do want to speed
up the lesson that you the pace that you
listen to things at just do little
increments especially on Spotify you can
do it in point one increments just creep
it up over time and uh you'll get there
the next Insight is just because
something is difficult to obtain does
not mean it's valuable yeah so this was
um I very fortunately got to do Rogan's
show in uh August of last year and he
dropped this bomb in the middle of the
episode that I've never heard anybody
speak about before and it's plain and
obvious in retrospect so he says this is
what I've termed Rogan's value
difficulty conflation
can I say I like to meme things uh look
at the car he's driving look at the
watch he's wearing look at the girl he's
with that's unattainable to many people
so it seems like it's valuable but then
you attained it and then you realized oh
this isn't valuable this is just
difficult to get and there's a
difference there's a big difference
what's valuable is something that
fulfills you intellectually emotionally
spiritually lovingly
and most smart people I think realize
that there is value in stepping outside
of your comfort right on the other side
of discomfort is something valuable and
we're told that worthwhile things are
difficult to attain because if they
weren't difficult to attain they
wouldn't be worthwhile
this is how non-valuable but difficult
things get slipped into our desires
without this noticing and it's people
who are actually using difficulty as the
measurement for Value rather than what
the actual True Value 100 difficulties
of proxy how do you
avoid that are there with difficulty
measurements
the guy should be a comedian
um
it's very hard because we're memetic
beings right we see what other people
want and we want to want what they want
um the memetic desire correct precisely
yeah we see that's a successful person
why don't I do what he does trying that
guy has a Great British accent I want
one you really should try and take this
on for a day it'd be great for you
um
yeah it's it's incredibly hard but
certainly spending a good bit of time
working on your values
what is it that you like what is it that
you genuinely want to want in life what
is it that you take pleasure in for
yourself uh what are you prideful about
in a good way
um those are the things once you've got
those down you can just run everything
through this heuristic it's a businessy
sort of talk uh really interesting
lesson that I learned about both Bezos
and musk so both of them had single
unidirectional ordinating principles for
both of their operations so every single
question that Bezos was asked in the
business went through does this make the
customer experience better
one ordinating principle unbelievably
simple for you to work out whether or
not you should say yes or no to
something if you only have one criteria
it's moving through for musk it was does
this get us closer to Mars everything
gets fed through that and I'm not saying
that you should have a single question
that your entire life is built around
you probably have multiple conflicting
sometimes even idiosyncrasies and bits
and pieces you want to do
however if you can reduce them down and
if you can maybe even write them down or
if you can have an idea of them in your
head it's going to make it easier the
next one is it's not coordination it's
cowardice yeah so this is great so this
is from Andrew Schultz and uh he may not
for the people that know him he's a
great comedian out of New York but you
may not think of him as like a font of
philosophical wisdom but this this
genuinely is so this is from an episode
that I did with him a lot of the time we
believe that there is a grand plan at
work to try and push a narrative or hurt
people from a particular group from the
outside it looks a lot like a
coordinated assault collusion
orchestrated by some malign Overlord
conspiracy but on the ground it doesn't
look anything like that it's just
individuals trying to save their own
skin and not get fired they've got an
expensive house they can barely pay and
the mortgage and a wife who wants a new
car and a private school for the kids
it's much easier for them to adhere to
whatever ideology will keep them in
their job rather than go against it sure
it might mean that they push an unhinged
story about whatever ideology people
don't like
but this doesn't mean that they've been
indoctrinated into some grand plan like
the incentives encourage execs and
influential actors and the people in
power to behave in particular and
aligned ways but the coordination is not
consciously conducted it's just a path
of least resistance for each person
so what that shows is that
the people who you are concerned are
trying to take over from an ideological
perspective
aren't coordinated they're just cowardly
and that actually makes any concern you
have about the direction that the world
is going in a little bit easier uh so
another thing that you said was so much
content and ideology is curated by a
pool getting installed in an executive's
yard
um so there's two two more great ideas
here that that relate to this that I
love one's called bonhoeffer's theory of
stupidity evil can be guided against
stupidity cannot and the the world's few
evil people have little power without
the help of the world's many stupid
people as a result stupidity is a far
greater threat than evil and obviously
as well one other thing that you know is
uh hanlon's razor never a tribute to
malice that which can be explained by so
it's fascinating because I think that
there's a lot of people over the last
three years that if I pulled the
audience whether it is uh public health
related whether it's economic and feder
related or even things in their local
communities they would be like this is
literally insane
and really
it's one thing for the people who are
making the decisions it's not
coordination it's cowardice yes what
about the people who are uh either
subjected to it or who uh are
participating in it although they are
not making the decision are they simply
just trying not to step out of line and
it's kind of like this like group thing
and kind of um social uh cohesion or is
there something else going on there I
think it's just very difficult like how
are you going to be this one person
trying to hold back a flood of the
entire organization behind you yeah
you've got the nomadic desire you don't
want to be the one that stands out you
don't want to be the person that's
pointed at as being the transfer by the
racist or the whatever that it is in
your office
but it's incredibly difficult and the
other thing is for all that I can say
it's not coordination it's cowardice it
doesn't make the impact of these sorts
of policies any easier on the people
that they impact you know if you're
somebody who's lost a job due to saying
some unspeakable thing
me going oh well at least it wasn't a
coordinated conspiracy mate like that
doesn't it's not going to help you feel
any better about about the fact that
you're no one employed so it's very
difficult but I think understanding that
makes the
foe if you want to call it that
less
impressive less Grand and you realize
that if people are acting in this
mimetic way all that you need to do is
change the ideology at the moment into
something which they also want to
replicate which you may see as being
better for the world
speaking of Schultz I taught on this
um there was a point where people went
after Joe Rogan and uh there was like a
pendulum swinging and it was very much
like are they going to try to cancel the
largest podcast in the world right and
Andrew was one of the first people to
stand up and be like dude I didn't know
this guy this guy's done incredible
things for my career he has been an
incredible friend behind the scenes you
know all kind of went out and put his
reputation online and put a flag on the
ground it was like I know this guy he is
not a racist yep
almost like dominoes another comedian
another comedian another comedian right
and and they all came and so what it
begs the question of is you always have
to have the first right the person who's
willing to kind of put the flag on the
ground first and then it is fascinating
to watch people go from following the
crowd out of fear or wanting to to fit
in to oh it's okay to say this other
thing oh let me go follow and I want to
be in that group it needs to be the
right person that says it first as well
you know if it was some unknown upcoming
well-respected but relatively small
comedian it wouldn't have worked but
because it should you know massive time
very big reach here's the other thing
right here's the reason that Rogan
didn't get canceled last year in my
opinion it's that
most of the news stories that try and
find The Smoking Gun that suggests the
racist bigot whoever it is is that
they're trying to accuse it of
what the thing is this is the tip of the
iceberg and you know nothing about what
looks below the surface but we do and we
always have the reason that it didn't
work for Rogan is that you have even a
casual fan of him having listened to 200
hours of this man thousand hours five
thousand hours of this man they go
you're telling me this is the tip of the
iceberg it's like
I've seen the whole Iceberg I know that
there's nothing lurking down there and
this is one of the great protectionist
strategies that you have if you do have
direct connection with your audience and
if you produce regularly and frequently
because you um expand the degrees of
freedom within which you could mess up
so to speak because your audience is
still going to have faith that you are
and they think of you as a human
precisely they humanize it yeah the next
one is uh absurd ideological beliefs or
shows of theality yes so this is it
falls straight on from what we've just
spoken about this is from guinda Bogle
one of my favorite sub Stacks an absurd
ideological belief is actually a form of
tribal signaling it signals to one's
ideology is more important to them than
reason itself than truth sanity to one's
allies this is an oath of unwavering
loyalty it's one's enemies this is a
threat display it's not always about
what's true it's often about how does
this make me look to my tribal
compatriots and to my enemies and this
again helps people to understand how
could this person hold this ridiculous
belief we all know that this isn't true
this flies in the face of reality you go
well what if the belief isn't about what
you're believing what if the belief is
about trying to hold a flag in the air
that says I am this kind of a person and
the more ridiculous the belief
stronger your show of field he is to the
organization or the group that you're a
part of because if you have to put aside
an awful lot of reality
in order to be able to believe this
thing they go wow like pumps a reliable
Ally you know he just disregarded the
laws of thermodynamics in place of in
place of like us and this so that was
just a very nice succinct way it's not
coordination it's cowardice and
ideological beliefs are like shows a
filthy and threat displays that really
to me helped to turn down the volume of
the culture War back and forth and
everybody gets caught up in it you know
no matter how much you try to avoid this
stuff you'll see something some
ridiculous video from whichever side you
do or don't like and uh both of those
things really helped to kind of just
turn the volume down a bit yeah those
are great uh the key to confidence
starts with action okay so this is
probably the best thing that I learned
last year and it's from Alex homozy he
says you don't become Confident by
shouting affirmations in the mirror but
by having a stack of undeniable proof
that you are who you say you are outwork
your self-doubt
that to me is like such a mic drop
that's money that's what I do my podcast
for to hear people say things like that
and I was chronically unconfident for a
long time in my 20s
as somebody that was standing in the
front door of a nightclub that was a
male model that did two reality TV shows
but I was very performative with the way
that I was doing this stuff because
inside I still didn't have
that genuine rock hard sense of of
something to be confident about and I
always wondered about why the people had
confidence and I presumed that it was a
mindset thing when I have come to
believe is that it's because I hadn't
created a stack of work
that I genuinely felt existentially
connected to
and was proud of I loved the work that I
did with my nightclub business but there
was always so many degrees of freedom
between the success of the business and
me and my inputs oh it's because of
market conditions oh it's because of how
effective all of the managers are oh
it's because all of our competitors went
away and this is one of the beautiful
things about any individual Pursuit
especially where you've got immediate
feedback it's why sports stars and
athletes are loads of in some ways a
very difficult existence it's a great
existence as well because they can see
the fruits of their labor immediately
you spend an amazing off-season building
up your strength you crush it next year
so for me
Rogan calls it uh building a mountain
with layers of paint
right one layer of paint at a time you
get what's a layer of paint nothing
absolutely nothing but after thousands
of iterations of this you end up with a
really big size mountain and that you
don't become Confident by shouting
affirmations in the mirror but by having
a stack of undeniable proof that you are
who you say you are outwork yourself
doubt just encapsulates that perfectly
and the key to confidence starts with
action for me is
re-jigging your mental state to be like
right tomorrow I'm going to wake up and
I'm going to be positive cool like that
that's not a bad thing you know more
power to you
but reality is going to come and smash
you in the face what you're going to be
if you want confidence without
competence you want delusion
and if you want competence without
confidence you want fantasy so it's like
look those things need to grow together
in my opinion it is much easier to do a
thing start doing it do it well and then
go okay after a while
your
old imposter Syndrome has no choice but
to be eroded by this mountain of
evidence that you've got and that for me
was the easiest way that I built up my
confidence I enjoy always talking to you
because a lot of these ideas start to
intertwine and uh I read a lot of books
and there's things that I will read in
one book that I'll see in another and
then in another in another and they
usually come from different walks of
life it's very similar with a podcast we
talk to a lot of different people you
start to see these commonalities and
this idea of the key to confidence
starts with action is almost perfectly
overlaid with almost every book you read
from someone who's successful at
something there is a theme of practice
whether they knew they were practicing
or not and so confidence comes from the
ability to know I've done this before
yes right and I can keep doing it
um and like maybe you start out you're
like I suck at this and that's kind of
the first couple layers of paint and
then eventually it's like okay well I'm
better than I was but I still suck and
eventually you're like hey I'm not half
bad and then like maybe you get to the
point where you're like okay I'll like
show somebody else what I can do yeah
and then you build that confidence which
really came again from that action
there's a quote from Seth Godin uh they
said on my show and he said um
a lot of the time you need support but
only the first time around and his point
there was that when you're starting out
with something
you haven't done it before how do you
expect to be confident at something
you've literally never done before you
have no evidence and this is where the
um Lone Wolf super Chad Alpha guy going
and Lone Ranger in it on his own uh
doesn't really work too well if you're
starting out it's all well and good if
you've gained Mastery in some domain and
have a huge audience and loads of people
like you and stuff and then you say
right I'm going to stick my middle
finger up all of these people I'm going
my own way you can't do that when you're
starting out because you need the
support of people around you just to get
over the hump of how hard becoming good
at anything is so yeah you need support
the first time around lean more heavily
on your Social Circles and then as you
become better and better you can
actually refine it a bit more the next
one is how to deal with the pain of
feeling things so very deeply
yes so this is from
um why Buddhism is true by Robert Wright
Robert Wright and evolutionary
psychologist who then uh turned to
meditation later in his career uh
evolutionary psychology and meditation
might not be two things that you
immediately bring together so he tried
to battle with this sort of polarity in
a book why Buddhism is true and the
quote from uh jungi manga rinpoche is
ultimately happiness comes down to
choosing between the discomfort of
becoming aware of your mental
afflictions or the discomfort of
becoming ruled by them
become aware of them or become ruled by
them and this pain of feeling things
deeply which many people in the audience
given that you're here learning and
trying to improve yourself and
reflecting and doing the introspection
certainly something that I resonated
with and still do for a long time
it's like opening Pandora's Box like
once you peer in and realize that you
are not all that you could be
that there is something better that you
could get out of yourself and out of
life and how you could contribute to the
world
as soon as you realize that you can't
close the lid on that box anymore and
you spend the remainder of your days
trying to meet the ideal that you've set
for yourself right and if if true Hal is
when the person that you are meets the
person that you could have been this can
be very painful and you can think you
know you look at a dog and it's just
wagging its tail and having a great time
you think oh it'd be so amazing to just
be that golden retriever you know I I
wouldn't have to go to work I wouldn't
have to worry about whether I'm enacting
my Logos I wouldn't get involved in
culture wars I wouldn't have to reply to
DMS and emails
and yeah you know like being a golden
retriever probably pretty fun but
I do think that
for the people who have peered inside of
Pandora's Box who know that there is
more that they could bring to the world
you can't put that toothpaste back in
the tube you can't regress back to some
other version of you where you're not
trying for Mastery and self-fulfillment
and and improving the entire globe and
leaving it a better place than when you
came you can't do that
so the choice is between learning more
about these challenges becoming as
competent as possible mastering whatever
you can in order to be able to Wrangle
this Peterson says uh you take more of
the thing that poisons you until you
turn it into a tonic that allows you to
girdle the world around you and this is
the way out is through right it's not oh
God I'm interested in some things and I
find the world difficult let's back away
from it and say okay cool game on I'm
ready for this and
ultimately happiness comes down to
choosing between the discomfort of
becoming aware of your mental
afflictions or the discomfort of being
becoming ruled by them for me
I don't want to be ruled by them I would
much sooner deal with the discomfort of
becoming aware of them the last one I
want to talk about is accept that all of
your heroes are full of
very very apt for both me and you to
finish on this one I think
um I when I saw this I literally was
like man that is spot on sorry yes so uh
this is from Jason Pagan and he says
Your Heroes aren't Gods they're just
regular people who probably got good at
One Thing by neglecting literally
everything else and this is the
description of every single high
performer that I've seen
in order to be good at one thing you
have to sacrifice more than the other
people that are only doing one thing and
prepared to sacrifice and the example
that I use for this all the time is
Eddie Hall so Eddie Hall British guy
World's Strongest Man 2018 and he
retires with the World's Strongest Man
Trophy in the air right his grandma died
a while ago and he's holding it up he's
saying Nana this is for you and he's
crying he's this big 200 kilo guy it's
beautiful
but he also says in an interview shortly
afterward that had he have not won the
world's strongest man on that date he
would have been dead divorced and with
no relationship to his kid because how
hard he was pushing his body presumably
the drugs that he was having to take as
well six foot four
440 pounds training every day uh he was
training so hard that his relationship
with his wife was breaking down he spent
no time with his kid because of how much
he was traveling to compete
that is a man who is sacrificed
everything in order to be good at one
thing
only in light of seeing the entirety of
someone's experience that is a high
performer and taking into account the
price that they pay for Brilliance and
greatness
can you see
truly whether you want that life to look
at Eddie Hall and say I want to be the
world's strongest man that sounds
amazing I hold it in the air and crying
in Nana brilliant
okay well do you want to nearly die
because of how high your blood pressure
is do you want to have the relationship
with your wife glance off the bottom of
divorce because of how destroyed the
relationships become do you want to lose
every single moment that you've got with
your daughter probably not you wouldn't
hate that price that's not to say that
people shouldn't Chase Excellence or
high performance what it is to say
Beware of the price that you need to pay
in order to become great and make sure
that you're prepared to pay it before
you go down that route
Before I Let You Go I want everyone to
take out your phone and immediately go
subscribe to the modern wisdom podcast
but can you share maybe one specific
episode that we can send people to that
you think can help whether there's
critical thinking independent thinking
or something that they'll get some value
out of absolutely yes so um
David Goggins only did two podcast
episodes uh for his most recent book one
of them is Rogan one of them was mine um
if you need some motivation David
Goggins is there Spotify is the best
place to go there's a follow button in
the middle of the page just press that
for me there's also a five star thing
and there's a website
um you can ding them for the accent but
the follow is the important what can I
say
um David Goggins would be good uh
another one that's very interesting from
a completely different
line of thinking would be gwynda Bogle
g-u-r-w-i-n-d-e Arts from the back end
of last year if you're such modern
wisdom goender or modern wisdom Goggins
both of them will come up on whatever
you listen on uh and the reason I love
that guy is that it's the entire episode
is like this so I'll find some of his
Concepts and we'll spend five minutes
just riffing on each of them
um and I really love this
quick sort of back and forth we've got
here's a concept we'll we'll do it you
know you guys maybe only one or two of
those things resonated with you but
you're like
cool I'm gonna go learn about that that
inaction thing or I'm gonna go learn
about that that coordination thing uh I
really appreciate it I really appreciate
everybody being so welcoming to me uh
since I've been here I appreciate you
for having me here man uh this event's
really really cool it's one of the first
live shows that I've done and uh I hope
that everyone enjoyed it Chris Williams
said everyone
yeah of course